what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and if
you're here you probably just saw
eternals and want to know what those
post-credit scenes are about now i've
been hearing that a lot of people are
confused about these two post credit
scenes even after watching some
breakdowns so my goal is going to be to
explain it in the most simplistic way
possible and i've actually noticed that
a few people have gotten one of the
post-credits scenes wrong this is not
their fault the director chloe zao came
out after and revealed a certain key
part to one of the post-credit scenes
adding clarity and confirming one thing
and of course i'll break that down and
needless to say this is a post-credit
scene explanation video so if you're
trying to avoid spoilers you should
click away also be sure to subscribe and
hit that bell to stay up to date on the
mcu and if you'd like a chance to win a
spider-man action figure subscribe to my
channel and the channel cosmic culture
and leave some comments on some videos
also right now let me know what you
thought about the eternals did you like
it or did you not like it now the first
mid credit scene is the one that
introduces the one and only harry styles
and not to brag but i did report on this
over a year ago so it's pretty cool to
see it happen but here is what's
happening in the mid credit scene now at
the very end of the movie before the
mid-credits scene are shem arrives and
he takes cersei kingo and fastos he
would have taken the other eternals but
they are on a ship in the middle of
space somewhere not on earth arishim
says you have chosen to sacrifice a
celestial for the people of this earth
he then says i will spare them but your
memories will show if they are worthy to
live and i will return for judgment he
then takes cersei kingo and fastus with
him and he's going to examine their
memories to determine the fate of the
people on earth this is where we get
into the mid-credits scene we go to the
eternals the ship the domo and we see
makari athena and druid and thena and
makari pick up on a presence that is
coming onto the ship they brace
themselves for an enemy but all of a
sudden a character teleports onto the
ship this is pip the troll pip the troll
comes from the planet laxadasia now
originally he didn't look like a troll
until one night he partied with some
trolls and he drank a liquor and he
turned into one he was then exiled from
his planet and eventually he teamed up
with adam warlock now it's recently been
announced that adam warlock will make
his mcu debut in guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 being played by will poulter
however pip is not with adam warlock in
the post-credits scene fina is about to
ask who pip is but pip interrupts
because he's about to announce who is
coming pip says behold the royal prince
of titan brother of thanos the knave of
hearts he then says the defeater of
black robert but quickly corrects it to
black roger the great adventurer star
fox now when star fox comes in he says
hello my fellow eternals thenos asks who
he is and he says i am aeros druid then
asks what he wants and then eros pulls
out the prime orb the same type of orb
that ajax and then cersei had which was
used to communicate with irishum aeros
then looks at the orb and says your
friends are in trouble and we know where
to find them okay so let's break this
down eros aka star fox is an eternal
this is why he says hello my fellow
eternals he is an eternal in the comics
and his brother is indeed thanos now
some people may be asking how that's
possible thanos doesn't look anything
like an eternal well in the comics
thanos is indeed an eternal he was born
of two eternal parents alars and sui-san
so thanos was born an eternal but he
inherited the deviant gene which is why
he looks oh purple and all messed up now
aeros parents are also thanos's parents
aeros is thanos's younger brother in the
comics the father alars established an
eternal settlement on titan you may
remember titan from avengers infinity
war thanos said that it was his home we
won't dive too deep into this in this
video i'll save it for another one let's
keep this video simple when arrow says
his friends are in trouble it's
obviously because eresham has taken them
now eros does have a prime orb since
alars his father was the one to
establish a settlement on titan we could
assume that his father had the prime orb
and communicated with a celestial
however it does seem like arrows and
perhaps a few other eternals found out
what the celestials were doing and much
like the eternals that we just watched
they decided to not go with what the
celestials wanted it looks like aeros
managed to flee and not get captured by
a celestial and is now trying to recruit
other eternals to go and save some of
his fellow eternals as well now the
question is where did arishem take the
other eternals they actually mentioned
this in the movie airshim is explaining
to serzei how the eternals were created
and he says that their home where they
were created is called the world forge
so this is going to be where they're
going to be heading down the line in the
mcu now one thing to take note of is
that pip the troll called arrows the
knave of heart and this is because his
power is literally the ability to get
women to fall in love with him aeros has
dated a lot of people in the marvel
universe including she-hulk and since
she-hulk is coming up i'm wondering if
there will be any type of connection
there but we'll have to wait and see on
that now i wouldn't be surprised if
marvel toned him down a lot in the mcu
and perhaps gave him different powers
but again we'll have to wait and see now
aeros and thanos never really got along
in the comics although we don't see much
interaction between them however arrows
does at one point become an avenger and
fight alongside them now for the post
credit scene in the film we're
introduced to dane whitman and he talks
about his family and how the history of
his family is very complicated that is
because he is actually the character or
will go on to be the character the black
knight now the first black knight
started with one of dane whitman's
ancestors sir percy of scandia the first
black knight he was eventually murdered
and it was passed down to another percy
descendant until eventually it got down
to dane whitman's uncle nathan garrett
now when he became the black knight he
decided that he was going to be a
villain now he would go on to be
mortally wounded in a fight against iron
man he fled and he called his nephew
dane whitman to his side he told him
everything and asked him to atone for
the mistakes that he made and return the
honor of their family legacy as the
black knight being a hero now this is
probably what dane whitman was referring
to when he was telling cersei that his
family history is complicated and this
takes us to the post-credits scene dane
is in an office presumably his and he's
debating on whether or not to open a
crate and take a sword that is inside of
it his family crest is on top of the
chest and you can tell that dane is
super nervous he opens it really quickly
and steps back because he starts to hear
a lot of voices you can't really make
them out but you can tell that something
is up with the sword on the top of the
chest when he opens it is markings that
say death is my reward dane says i'm
sorry but i have to try saying sorry
most likely to his ancestors that came
before him because as we know the mcu
doesn't keep origin stories as they are
in the comics more on this in a second
dane reaches towards the sword and part
of the sword is showing not wrapped up
and it appears that the sword is
somewhat alive having some black stuff
on it that reaches out towards dane as
he goes to touch it now right before he
touches it he hears a voice from behind
him that says are you sure you're ready
for that mr whitman now this voice has
been confirmed originally i did think it
was a watcher and a lot of people are
saying it is the watcher however the
director came out and said that it is
blade it is the voice of mahershala ali
who is going to be playing blade so it
looks like the eternals post credit
scene just confirmed that the black
knight and blade will be teaming up in
the mcu at some point in time and again
this was confirmed to be blade's voice
by the director chloe saw in an
interview with fandom now what this
post-credit scene is doing is setting up
dane whitman to become the black knight
in the mcu and this sword that he's
about to touch is the ebony blade
however there's a little bit of a trick
to the ebony blade the blade was a
magical blade forged by the wizard
merlin and dane whitman's ancestor sir
percy it was formed from the starstone
meteorite the blade is enchanted to cut
through any object it can prevent death
of its wielder and it can deflect any
type of magic however it was also
revealed to be cursed null the symbiote
god revealed the true nature of the
ebony blade the curse was that it would
slowly corrupt any user and cause a lust
for violence bloodshed and death
according to knoll it can only be
wielded by the impure of heart drawing
out their negative emotions until they
become bloodthirsty berserkers so yes
it's enchanted and can cut through
anything and deflect magic but it comes
at a pretty high cost now dane most
likely knows something about this which
is why he's so nervous to even open the
chest but this also means that he
probably knows that once he grabs it he
will become the black knight but like i
mentioned there is a pretty big curse
that comes with it which is why blade
shows up and says are you sure you want
to do that and those are the two
eternals post credits scene if you
enjoyed the eternals and want more
breakdowns on what happened in the movie
in the post credit scenes be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos be sure to let me know
what you thought about the eternals in
the comments down below and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram twitter and tick tock as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof